we are now one leg of the Triple Crown
shy of seeing yet another Triple Crown
winner and yet another Triple Crown
winner from Bob Baffert who's American
Pharoah or as you called him Chris
Brockman American American Pharoah uh
back in the day that was the last Triple
Crown winner justify where is the
Belmont Stakes win Iowa from making it
back to back in that regard for Bob
Baffert who's here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Bob
thanks for having me and you want to see
a real great reality show just better
tune in the Belmont three weeks I like
it I like it so walk me through what
that reality show is gonna look like Bob
you want to preview for it preview for
well we're we're we're almost there were
two thirds of the way which is probably
the toughest part and the horse you know
his Kentucky Derby was just awesome came
back had to work for it you know he had
a you sort of had a will himself in
there he got a lot of pressure early
from the champion horse and there was it
was a good it was a good like little
match race going on but he held them all
off and in the mud again so and came out
of the race looks fantastic so you know
so far I like and like what I see is but
still gonna be a tough race he's going
to have to give us another big run but
he's just an incredible horse an
incredible animal just like American
Pharoah just so talented so you know I
think it's um you know we're feeling you
know just we're feeling good about it
but it's still you know we you know we
still have three weeks to go and what
can happen but III think it's a it's a
race that you know everybody should tune
in because I can't believe I'm you know
we just went through it just a 2015 and
after 37 years and here I get a chances
my fifth time I get to go through this
so I'm pretty pretty blessed to even
have horses like this but to go through
it hand is pretty pretty exciting before
we turn the page Bob to to the Belmont I
still want to rest on the Preakness a
little bit there it's funny when you
said what what you see in the horse I
couldn't see the horse just sitting in
for where I
is that the foggiest race you've ever
been a part of mom yeah you know what it
was the weather unfortunately was you
know it was a great event but it was the
weather just but it rained every day for
five days and but all of a sudden it
quit raining and all of a sudden the fog
came in and if in the track was starting
to dry out so it was getting a little
sticky and I was worried about that
because it gets a little bit tiring but
it was weird we you know you could you
could barely see the break and I was
watching on the monitor just like
everybody else and all of a sudden they
went to the first turn they sort of
disappeared a little bit then we saw him
in the back side and the far turn they
disappeared so there was about 15
seconds where I was just watching and
I'm just saying to everybody around me
well I hope he's on the lead when he
comes out of the fog sure enough he was
on the lead lap good you know so it was
it was incredible there it's there the
classics are just they're incredible
they're they're tough races and this
year there's some really top
three-year-old it's a tough it's a tough
bunch so it's like I compared it liked
it it's the SEC every race man it's
tough and soberly you know we're
enjoying the ride and because you never
know when you you know we may never be
back but we just have an incredible
horse and then and so we're just you
know just to find he's a beautiful he's
a little gorgeous looking animal so
we're you know we're just you know
keeping our fingers crossed and you know
hoping everything goes well Bob Baffert
Hall of Fame trainer here on the Rich
Eisen show tell me about the first day
you laid eyes on justified Bob well I
just when they sent him to me and I got
him I got him laid I got him in in late
November and so he didn't run as a tea
roll so there was a big it was called
the Apollo curse there had never been a
Derby winner that has won the Derby
since 1882 so he was dealing with that
so he broke that curse so so he this
horse is really he's changed he's you
know he's making history
for himself and for me and so he has
just the most beautiful animal and I
knew the first time we work and we knew
he was really special but I I didn't get
a race into him till January and now
he's run five races every three weeks
which is just unheard of horses just
don't you know it's hard to keep
bringing it and bringing it just like
it's just like these these teams playing
these top teams every week you know it's
like you know and and this one was it
was close you know it was it was closed
it was a little closer you know the
comfort is usually he wins his races
pretty handily and so but he had really
worked for it but it was it was a tough
race it never been battle tested and and
he was this this weekend so hopefully
we're you know he looked he looked great
and came out of well so we're just well
um you know - I'm just saying that if
you're gonna want to do you want to go
to the Belmont this you know I would say
it's it's worth going to watch this
horse run okay so when when just a
couple more questions for you here Bob
what what does a special horse look like
what what do you see in a horse and you
could say that's special
it's their mechanics the way they move
like any great athlete is he just they
moved they had this fluid way moving
he's just a big he's a big strong horse
he's a little bit bigger than American
Pharoah and but American Pharoah is the
same way they just they did just
effortless they move effortlessly and
and when horses come to them they can
just get away from big and just open up
on them it's just like you know those
special horses just like you know you
when you see Usain Bolt you know you say
you don't see one ever here they come
around you know every five eight ten
years something likes special like that
like the old like Seattle Slew
Secretariat they're just rare just uh
just a genetic something really worked
well and so um and that's what they are
they're just superior animals and what's
your confidence level in justify going
into the Belmont compared to how you
felt about American Pharoah going into
the Belmont a couple years ago Bob well
American Pharoah you know he was I felt
really good about him you know but you
don't until the last week coming up to
it then you you know but coming out of
the Preakness last year I felt really
really good about it I feel good about
it with this horse because he's that
kind of horse so you still have to have
racing luck though you know things can
happen you know they can brake poorly or
something I remember war emblem he's
stumbled badly at the start you still so
I don't like I don't get ahead of myself
but I mean this horse I mean he's
definitely the best horse of this group
but he still needs to you know can't
throw any interceptions those things can
happen and the question is of
audible.com crown hopes with your own
friendly fire in that regard what's your
philosophy here they ran another horse
clip he was seeing ownership in the
Preakness they ran him in there so you
know what we don't worry about that you
know it's not supposed to be easy
it's not you know and so they have
different trainers and they're trying to
win also so you know I'm like you know
that's that's that's what makes the the
Triple Crown so unique you're gonna
catch fresh horses you know but hey if
you're great you know that's what makes
it it's so when you do win it just it
makes it special because you have to
there's a lot of obstacles to get there
and so you know that's just part of the
game and and so we're all right I don't
I can't worry about stuff like that I
just worry about my horse what do you
think the odds are of audible running
right now are I had no idea I don't
really talk about out of all you know
they're you know that the plan was to
run them so I just don't know okay
alright Bob and the horse justify as you
keep you said it looks great it came
through the horse great you had an
interesting line about gravel when you
when you after the Preakness that there
was no gravel around so everything's
good right with justified yeah he was
you know a lot of times when the
run these horses on a wet sealed track
they're hard they can big come up but
just like a you know I was compared to a
woman wearing her high heels and you go
to a function you have little blister it
takes a couple days and it's gone and
sort of the same thing you know you just
get a little he had a little spot there
we had you bruises heal because it's a
wet track sir it can be abrasive as
they're running sand it sweats and so
they're there all the way around there
but know that that thing was with him 48
hours it was gone so it was it was a
non-factor what's the horse's reward for
winning Bob gets a lot of love and oats
you know you want they just want to eat
they want to eat and they want to be
massaged and rub down but they want to
eat and they get they pamper we pamper
their they get they get a lot of rubdown
and last one for you Bob this is maybe
off the board if you will far afield but
you know we hear about justifies great
in the wet weather and the slop your
hair do you didn't have a bad hair day
at all Bob are you are you the same
because I'm this is the sort of stuff I
noticed being a follically challenged
guy I mean you you look like you had a
great hair day that day Bob I don't know
I've seen a little yellow pin in I gotta
hit the purple shampoo a little harder I
think you know that's s okay but it's
right here is my you know it's I get it
from my mother my mother gave me this
this white hair and it's like my lot of
people they don't know who I am but I'll
be going somewhere
through an airport there aren't you that
horse guy you know that that's me
you're Brando it's your brand my brand
my hair is my brand yeah but so its own
down it's all in the breeding is
basically what you're saying Don the
rain it comes from my mother she was
completely white when she was 30 and I
was too so I I've got it so yeah you're
that you're like the Steve Martin
hey you're telling me Bob congratulate
you still have it that's for damn sure
man and congrats on on the first two
legs and hopefully we'll chat after the
Belmont to
oh thanks for having me always that's
Bob back a Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience